EXCELLENT REPORTING.
I'M SURE WE WILL BE CHECKING
BACK IN WITH YOU THROUGHOUT THE
REST OF THE HOUR.
HERE AND I FORMER NYPD
COMMISSIONER BERNIE KERIK AND
DAN BONGINO, FORMER NYPD OFFICER
AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
BERNARD, THE S.W.A.T. TEAM
SITUATION IN PHILADELPHIA, A
ROLE HOME, NOT A LOT OF
ENTRANCES, HOW DOES THE S.W.A.T.
TEAM TO TACTICALLY GO UP IN
THERE AND MANAGED TO RESCUE
MULTIPLE INDIVIDUALS WHILE ON
THE FIRST FLOOR, YOU HAVE A
GUNMAN WITH AN AR-15 AND
MULTIPLE HANDGUNS?
>> LOOK, KEEP IN MIND BEFORE
THEY GET IN THERE, THEY WILL
TALK TO THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
ALREADY IN THE BUILDING HERE
THAN NARCOTICS GUYS, BUT BEFORE
THEY DO A SEARCH WARRANT, THEY
WILL HAVE A TACTICAL PLAN,
LAYOUT WITH THE BUILDING LOOKS
LIKE, SOME BASIC IDEAS, AND
THERE WILL BE OTHER INTELLIGENCE
THAT THEY GATHER.
THEY SET UP CAMERAS, PUT PINHOLE
CAMERAS, A BUNCH OF STUFF, THEY
MAY PUT UP A DRONE TO GET A LOOK
IN THE WINDOWS.
A BUNCH OF STUFF THEY CAN DO TO
GIVE THEM INSIGHT TO GET UP INTO
THE BUILDING.
AND I CAN TELL YOU, THE
PHILADELPHIA S.W.A.T. TEAM IS
ONE OF THE BEST, PROBABLY, IN
THE NORTHEAST.
ON THE BOTTOM LINE, HERE'S THE
REALITY: THAT GUY IS WALKING OUT
OR HE IS COMING OUT ON A GURNEY,
ONE OR THE OTHER.
>> Jesse: DAN, I IMAGINE NOW
THE HOSTAGES HAVE BEEN REMOVED
FROM THE HOME, THEY HAVE NOW ONE
INDIVIDUAL THAT HAS GONE FROM A
HOSTAGE SITUATION TO A
BARRICADED, COP SHOOTER
SITUATION.
TIME IS RUNNING OUT FOR HIM.
HE'S GOT LITERALLY NO OPTIONS
NOW LEFT.
I WOULD THINK THE POLICE WOULD
BE AT A HUGE TACTICAL ADVANTAGE
AT THIS POINT, AND CAN KIND OF
CHOOSE THEIR SPOT ACCORDINGLY.
>> YEAH, YOU'RE RIGHT.
PHYSIOLOGICALLY, EVENTUALLY, THE
PURPOSE IS GOING TO NEED TO
SLEEP.
OBVIOUSLY.
I DON'T CARE HOW MUCH DRUGS HE
HAS IN HIS SYSTEM OR IN THE
APARTMENT, YOU ARE NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO STAY UP ALL NIGHT.
EVENTUALLY THE BODY IS GOING TO
SHUT DOWN.
AND JESSIE, YOU REMEMBER, POLICE
OFFICERS CAN CHANGE SHIFTS.
THE BAD GUY CAN'T.
HE IS IN THERE BY HIMSELF, ONLY
HIM RIGHT NOW.
JUST ADDING ON TO WHAT BERNIE
SAID, HE'S RIGHT, THE POLICE
OFFICERS, BEFORE THEY DO THESE
RAIDS, TRY TO DO THE BEST TO GET
A LAYOUT OF WHAT A SIMILAR
APARTMENT MIGHT LOOK LIKE.
THERE NEVER REALLY GOING IN
BLIND.
ON THE DOWNSIDE, THE PERP
DEFINITELY HAS SOME MASTERY OF
THE TERRAIN FEATURES.
HE'S IN THE BUILDING, SO HE'S
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO KNOW BETTER
WITH THE INSIDE OF THE BUILDING
LOOKS LIKE.
THE PROBLEM THERE IS YOU RUN
INTO THINGS CALLED FATAL
FUNNELS.
IN OTHER WORDS, WHEN THE
OFFICERS COME IN, THERE IS
USUALLY ONLY ONE WAY TO ENTER AN
APARTMENT, WHERE THE BAD GUY CAN
OBVIOUSLY FUNNEL HIS ATTENTION.
IF YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT I MEAN.
THE POLICE OFFICERS DON'T HAVE
THAT LUXURY, AND IT JUST GOES TO
SHOW YOU AGAIN, JESSE, CAN'T SAY
ENOUGH ON THE NETWORK, HOW BRAVE
THESE GUYS AND WOMEN REALLY ARE.
AND THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY
ARE WALKING INTO WHEN THEY WALK
IN THERE, MAKE NO MISTAKE.
>> Jesse: SO WE DON'T KNOW IF
THIS GUY IS INTOXICATED.
WE OBVIOUSLY KNOW HE IS SCARED,
HE'S GOT THE ADRENALINE PUMPING.
HE'S GOT A LOT OF ROUNDS,
APPARENTLY, BECAUSE IT'S ALREADY
FIRED OFF AROUND 100.
HE'S HAD HIS GIRLFRIEND ON THE
LINE AT SOME POINT.
HAD HIS ATTORNEY TRYING TO HELP
NEGOTIATE THIS THING DOWN AT
THIS POINT.
WITH THE NEGOTIATING STRATEGY AT
THIS POINT WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT?
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW, IT'S REALLY
JUST A NEGOTIATION.
>> MOST OF THE NEGOTIATIONS WILL
BE BASED AROUND FAMILY, KIDS,
GIRLFRIENDS, FRIENDS, THE
ATTORNEY, THE ATTORNEY IS A BIG
ONE BECAUSE THE ATTORNEY, HE'S
GOING TO BE THE ONE THAT GOT
HIM TO WALK OUT.
HE'S GOING TO BE THE ONE THAT
TELLS HIM, LOOK, THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO HURT YOU.
HE'S GOING TO BE THE ONE THAT
SAYS IT IS NOT AS BAD AS YOU
THINK.
BOTTOM LINE IS IT'S BAD.
IT'S ATTEMPTED MURDER OF SIX
COPS.
BUT BOTTOM LINE, YOU KNOW, THE
COPS HAVE ALL NIGHT.
THEY HAVE ALL NIGHT, THEY HAVE
ALL DAY TOMORROW.
HE HAS TO GO TO SLEEP.
HE HAS TO SHUT DOWN.
HE WILL SHUT DOWN.
AND THEY WILL PICK THEIR TIME.
>> Jesse: THIS ALL GOES BACK,
NOT THE GUNS COME IN MY OPINION,
DAN.
THIS IS ABOUT NARCOTICS.
THIS ABOUT CARTELS SENDING
MASSIVE QUANTITIES OF NARCOTICS
INTO NORTH PHILADELPHIA, WHETHER
IT'S PCP OR HEROIN, CRACK
COCAINE, OPIOIDS, THEY FLED THE
STREETS.
THEY GIVE IT TO THE GANG
LEADERS, WHO THEN DISTRIBUTED IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD AND RUN IT UP
AND DOWN THE EAST COAST
CORRIDORS.
AND THEY HAVE TO HAVE THESE
WEAPONS TO PROTECT THE PRODUCT.
TO BLAME THIS ON GUNS, LIKE THIS
GUY WITH THE AR -- THE HANDGUN,
DIDN'T GO THROUGH A BACKGROUND
CHECK.
IT'S CRAZY.
AND I THINK EVERYONE NEEDS TO
FOCUS ON WHAT THE REAL ISSUE
HERE IS.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, CAN I JUST
THROW A TIP OUT THERE FOR THE
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES?
MAY BE SHUT YOUR PIE HOLES --
I'M SERIOUS, LET THE COPS ON THE
GROUND, GET THIS GUY, THIS
MANIAC OUT OF THE BUILDING, AND
LET'S GET THE COPS OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL BEFORE WE START
TWEETING ABOUT OUR NEXT
BRILLIANT GUN CONTROL PLAN.
THAT, BY THE WAY, THIS
CRIMINAL -- AS YOU JUST
ACCURATELY STATED -- COULDN'T
CARE LESS ABOUT.
I'M SURE THIS GUY DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT YOUR LATEST BACKGROUND
CHECK PROPOSAL.
SO CAN WE ALL JUST LIKE FOCUS ON
THE COPS ON THE TACTICS NOW?
GETTING PEOPLE OUT OF THERE
SAFELY.
AND BY THE WAY, THE RESIDENTS,
JESSE.
THERE ARE STILL PEOPLE WHO LIVE
AROUND THERE.
BEFORE WE ARE TWEETING OUR
STUPID ELECTORAL PLANS TO CATCH
ANOTHER CARCASS BOAT IN IOWA --
I MEAN, HOW INSENSITIVE.
NOT UNBELIEVABLE, VERY
BELIEVABLE, BUT UNBELIEVABLY
INSENSITIVE.
>> Jesse: KAMALA HARRIS WAS I
BELIEVE ON ANOTHER AT NETWORK AS
THE SHOOTING WAS UNFOLDING, AS
POLICE OFFICERS WERE BEING
RUSHED TO THE HOSPITAL TO GET
THEIR WOUNDS HEALED.
AND FIRST THING OUT OF HER MOUTH
WAS POLITICAL, AND IT WAS ABOUT
GUN CONTROL.
LET'S LISTEN TO THE OUTCOME THAN
BURNING, YOU CAN REACT.
>> WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO
THESE INITIAL REPORTS -- I
STRESS THE WORD INITIAL REPORT.
>> IT'S NONSTOP, RIGHT?
PART OF MY FOCUS IS SMART GUN
SAFETY LAWS, RECOGNIZE THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE MORE ENFORCEMENT
AROUND GUN DEALERS.
>> Jesse: JUST DIDN'T REALLY
STRIKE THE RIGHT TONE THERE
APPEARED >> YOU KNOW WHEN SHE
DID THAT, I SENT OUT A TWEET.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THOSE
COPS.
IT'S ALL ABOUT POLITICS FOR HER
AND THE OTHER DEMOCRATS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS, THAT'S
RECKLESS, IT'S IRRESPONSIBLE,
SHOULDN'T HAVE HAPPENED.
IT SHOULDN'T HAPPEN IN THE
FUTURE, BUT IT WILL CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN BECAUSE THAT IS ALL THEY
CARE ABOUT.
>> Jesse: AND DAN, I BELIEVE
CORY BOOKER, ALSO RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT, SAID SOMETHING ON
MSNBC.
LET'S LISTEN TO THAT.
>> SOME OF THE MOST COURAGEOUS
OFFICERS WHEN I WAS A MAYOR, RUN
INTO BUILDINGS WHERE THEY HAVE
NO SITUATIONAL AWARENESS,
ENCOUNTER WEAPONS THAT HAVE NO
BUSINESS BEING ON OUR STREETS
COME IN THE HANDS OF PEOPLE THAT
WOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
GET THEM IF WE HAD THE MOST
COMMON SENSE BACKGROUND CHECKS
PAIRED OFF AND THE VOICES YOU
HEAR, CALLING FOR IT, THE KIND
OF GUN SAFETY THAT I HAVE PUT IN
MY VERY BOLD PLAN, OUR POLICE
OFFICERS WANTING IT TO HAPPEN,
BECAUSE THEIR LIVES ARE GETTING
INCREASINGLY DANGEROUS.
>> Jesse: DAN, I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THAT, BUT I KNOW THIS,
WHENEVER THERE IS A TERRORIST
ATTACK IN HIS COUNTRY, THEY SAY
HEY, HEY, PUMP THE BRAKES, DON'T
SAY ANYTHING, DON'T RUSH TO
JUDGMENT, LET THE FACTS COME IN,
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT MOTIVATED
THIS, WHO WAS INVOLVED IN THIS.
BUT AS PEOPLE ARE BEING TAKEN TO
THE HOSPITAL, THEY ARE ALREADY
PUSHING A POLITICAL AGENDA HERE,
AND MAKING ALL SORTS OF WILD
ASSUMPTIONS.
>> JESSE, WE HAVE AN ARMED
GUNMEN WITH COVER AND
CONCEALMENT IN A LOCATION, WHO
JUST TRIED TO KILL UPWARDS OF
30 OR 40 COPS AND INJURED SIX OF
THEM, POSSIBLY MORE.
SADLY, THE TIME PERIOD BETWEEN
THE HOT ZONE BREAKOUT, WITH THE
INCIDENT HAPPENS, AND THE
POLITICAL STUPIDITY, IT WENT
FROM ABOUT 48 HOURS A DECADE
AGO, TO ABOUT 48 SECONDS NOW.
I MEAN, THESE ARE SOME OF THE
MOST GROSSLY INSENSITIVE
COMMENTS.
YOU HAVE FAMILIES OF THESE
OFFICERS THAT ARE ON THE SCENE
WITH AN ARMED GUNMEN, AND YOU
WERE ON OTHER NETWORKS TALKING
ABOUT YOUR NEW POLICY
PRESCRIPTIONS?
I MEAN, HOW DENSE, YOUR SKULL
HAS TO BE LIKE 6 FEET THICK TO
PUT THAT OUT THERE RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS WHY I SAID -- I TWEETED
OUT TONIGHT, EVERYBODY JUST SHUT
YOUR PIE HOLES FOR A MINUTE AND
LET THE PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR A
LIVING, THE COPS, NOT THE
POLITICIANS, YOU GUYS AND LADIES
DON'T WORK, THAT'S NOT A REAL
JOB TO LET THE COPS WHO ACTUALLY
WORK FOR A LIVING LIKE BERNIE
AND I DID ONCE, LET THEM DO
THEIR JOBS.
JUST SHUT UP!
NOBODY EVER GOT IN TROUBLE,
JESSE -- I'M SORRY, I'M REALLY
UPSET RIGHT NOW.
NOBODY EVER GOT IN TROUBLE FOR
SHUTTING THE HILL UP.
JUST BE QUIET.
NOBODY NEEDS TO HEAR FROM YOU
RIGHT NOW.
CORY BOOKER IS NOT THE TACTILE
COMMANDER ON THE SCENE.
THIS GUY DOESN'T KNOW SQUAT.
HE DOESN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
POLICING.
JUST SHUT UP!
THAT THE COPS FIGURE IT OUT.
THERE WILL BE A TIME TO ARGUE
GUN CONTROL, WHATEVER YOU THINK
GUN CONTROL MEANS, IN    IN A DY
ORATORICAL PIER JUST SHUT UP,
GIVE IT THE 24-HOUR RULE PEERED
WHAT'S THE
PROBLEM?
>> Jesse: IT'S ALL RIGHT, YOU
CAN CALL ME JENNY, I DON'T MIND.
>> I'M REALLY UPSET, YOU KNOW I
LOVE YOU.
>> Jesse: YOU WERE SAYING
BOOKER CONTRADICTED HIMSELF.
>> HE'S TALKING ABOUT THE
WEAPONS, GOOD BACKGROUND CHECK
WOULD HAVE STOPPED IT -- NO, DO
IT, ARE CRIMINALS.
THEY CAN'T DO BACKGROUND CHECKS,
THEY CAN'T GET THAT GUN.
HE'S A.
>> Jesse: SO I WAS TALKING
EARLIER ABOUT THE NORTH
PHILADELPHIA REGION, AND THIS
ACTUAL NEIGHBORHOOD IN THIS
SECTION OF NORTH PHILADELPHIA IS
THE WORST NEIGHBORHOOD IN THE
ENTIRE CITY OF PHILADELPHIA.
HIGHEST CRIME RATE, MOST AMOUNT
OF DRUGS, MOST AMOUNT OF
POVERTY, AND NORTH PHILADELPHIA
WAS NOT ALWAYS LIKE THIS.
IN THE '40s, '50s, '60s,
EVEN THE EARLY '70s, THEY HAD
A LOT OF JOBS, STEEL,
MANUFACTURING, SHIPPING,
PACKAGING, THEY HAD GOOD, SOLID
JOBS.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN, POLITICIANS
LET THESE JOBS FLOAT OVERSEAS,
AND THEN THERE IS NO WAY TO MAKE
MONEY ANYMORE, EXCEPT SELL DRUGS
AND THEN MURDER ANYBODY THAT
GETS IN YOUR WAY.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
WRECK THESE CITIES.
YOU GOT HUGE SPIKES IN
HOMICIDES.
PHILADELPHIA, LAST YEAR, HAVE
THE HIGHEST HOMICIDE RATE IN THE
LAST TEN YEARS.
AND THIS YEAR, IN AUGUST, RIGHT
NOW, THEY ARE ALREADY ON RECORD
TO BE THAT.
SO SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE TO
GET A HOLD ON THESE CITIES,,
BECAUSE WHAT IS    EVER IS HAPPE
BECAUSE WHAT IS    EVER IS HAPPI
BECAUSE WHAT IS    EVER IS HAPPG
RIGHT NOW, IT'S NOT WORKING.
>> JESSE, MY FELLOW PANELIST,
BERNIE, WHAT HAPPENED WITH RUDY
GIULIANI AND BROKEN WINDOWS?
YOU ARE THE COMMISSIONER, YOU
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED HERE
THEY BROUGHT IN POLICE
COMMANDERS -- LISTEN, I WAS A
COP, I WORKED THERE, THEY
BROUGHT IN POLICE COMMANDERS AND
SAID LISTEN, WHAT'S GOING ON IN
YOUR QUARTER OVER THERE?
NOTHING, JUST LOW-LEVEL DRUG
DEALING.
AND WHAT DID BERNIE COME IN THE
FIRST DEPUTY COMMISSIONER SAY,
WE'RE NOT TOO COMFORTABLE WITH
THAT.
YOU'RE GOING TO CLEAN THAT UP.
JESSE, I'M TELLING YOU, THESE
POLICE COMMANDERS WERE SHOCKED,
THEY WERE USED TO RUNNING THINGS
THEMSELVES.
WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET AD, THE
SOLUTIONS ARE OUT THERE.
A GOOD LAW AND ORDER, QUALITY
POLICING, WHERE MAYORS AND
POLITICAL LEADERS, WHO ARE
USUALLY CLUELESS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE REAL JOBS, THEY CAN
ACTUALLY SUPPORT THE COPS COME
ON LIKE THEY DO NOW.
LET THE COPS DO THEIR JOB, LET
PEOPLE LIKE BERNIE AND OTHERS,
WHO UNDERSTAND CLEANUP THE CITY
JUST LIKE GIULIANI, BERNIE, AND
OTHERS DID IN NEW YORK.
IT WASN'T A MYSTERY WHAT
HAPPENED, THEY JUST GOT